thanks guys it's late at night here in
London but these two players fabiano
caruana and his opponent veselin topalov
battled it out for six and a half hours
showing some fireworks across the board
it was back and forth fabiano what's
your take on the game I think I've till
opening I had a clear advantage after c4
maybe I shouldn't play be 4i I wanted to
to get some positional edge but maybe
c64 some something a bit more aggressive
was better and then I just played badly
I got completely outplayed I went from a
fine position to a nearly losing or
completely losing position after the
time control i think it was close to
hopeless but um I found some tricks I
think rook CA was an important movement
and after that I don't know if he had a
clear win or anything it was very close
to winning but somehow I managed to hold
it now that we're nearing the halfway
point here in London what are your
thoughts for the rest of the tournament
do you have expectations about the games
going forward if I played better than I
did today it should be all right great
well you heard it from fabiano caruana
himself so let's see what the rest of
the tournament brings back to you guys